>> Larry: YEAH.
WELCOME BACK.
I AM HERE WITH MY PANEL,
COMEDIAN AND SHOW RUNNER HERE AT
THE NIGHTLY SHOW, RORY ALBANESE.
AND RETURNING TO THE SHOW,
WRITER AND COMEDIAN, BARATUNDE
THURSTON.
AND HIS NEW DOCUMENTARY, CALL ME
LUCKY OPENS AUGUST 7TH, COMEDIAN
AND DIRECTOR, BOBCAT GOLDTHWAIT.
OKAY.
GUYS.
WE HAVE GOT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
HUNTING STORY.
THIS THING IS UNBELIEVABLE.
OF COURSE IT HAS BEEN ALL OVER
THE NEWS, THIS DENTIST FROM
MINNESOTA AND ALL OF THAT, WENT
TO ZIMBABWE ON A HUNTING TRIP,
KILLED CECIL THE BELOVED LION.
TWITTER IS BLOWING UP ABOUT
THIS.
I WANT TO KNOW, DOES ANYBODY
THINK HUNTING IS STILL OKAY?  IT
FEELS LIKE ONE OF THOSE THINGS
LIKE BOXING.
>> I FEEL THAT -- I AM ALL FOR,
ACTUALLY YEAH, I AM ALL FOR
HUNTERS OWNING GUNS BECAUSE IT
INCREASES THE ODDS OF TWO
REDNECKS BLOWING EACH OTHER'S
HEADS OFF.
THAT MIGHT BE FINE.
>> ACCIDENTAL HUNTING.
>> DICK CHENEY STYLE.
>> RIGHT.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE A DUDE.
WHY WE BROKE UP.
>> Larry: EXACTLY.
IT FEELS ANTIQUATED TO ME.
BUT IT'S INTERESTING,  IN OUR
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS WE ALWAYS
HAVE TO DO THAT GUN PHOTO-OP.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> AND THAT'S ALL ABOUT HUNTING,
RIGHT?  IT IS NOT ABOUT YOU CAN
USE A GUN BECAUSE THEY ARE SHOWN
SHOOTING SOMETHING WHICH IS
SUPPOSEDLY AN ANIMAL.
SO IT IS LIKE WE WANT OUR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO BE
ABLE TO KILL GAME, RIGHT?
>> WE MISSED SOMETHING FROM OUR
PAST AS HUMAN BEINGS AND I THINK
WE DON'T REALLY FIGHT THAT MUCH
ANYMORE, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
SOCIETY.
WE HAVE LAWYERS NOW, AND THAT'S
A LOT LESS EXCITING FOR PEOPLE.
>> AND THEN YOU SAY 50-YEAR-OLD
MINNESOTA DENTISTS AND THAT
DOESN'T EXACTLY IMPLY RAMBO.
RIGHT?  HE IS ACTING OUT SOME
KIND OF FANTASY HE CAN CLEARLY
NOT DO IN THAT CHAIR.
>> HE WANTS TO BE BADASS
>> IF YOU WANT TO IMPRESS ME,
BEING A
BAD-ASS, YOU KNOW, FLY TO AFRICA
AND (BLEEP) A TIGER.
YEAH.
I WOULD BE IMPRESSED.
>> YES.
>> BY THE WAY --
>> IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
>> NO, I WAS GOING TO SAY
TRAVELOCITY HAS GREAT DEALS ON
THAT.
>> I AM NOT TRYING TO PLUG OR
ANYTHING --
>>
ENOUGH, WHEN PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
OF DENTISTS, PEOPLE WON'T GET
THEIR ROOT CANAL BECAUSE THEY
ARE AFRAID WITH THIS GUY IN A
CROSSBOW TO MESS WITH THEM.
>> IF YOU ARE SITTING IN THE
CHAIR AND YOU HAVE A BIG MOOSE
LOOKING AT YOU OR SOMETHING,
THEY ARE TERRIFYING.
>> I ALSO THINK TOO IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT YOU ARE HUNTING, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE IT IS A DEFINITE
FACTOR.
IF YOU ARE HUNTING A LION AND
THERE IS NOT THAT MANY LEFT,
LIKE THERE SHOULD BE AN EQUATION
LIKE IF THERE IS MORE PEOPLE ON
AN ISLANDERS GAME THAN
THERE ARE OF THE SPECIES YOU
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO KILL IT.
IT IS LIKE -- AND ANYTHING WITH
A NAME, I FEEL LIKE --
>> ONCE YOU NAME IT --
>> THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD NEVER
NAME RATS IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> YES.
EXACTLY.
YOU KILLED JERRY.
WHAT THE (BLEEP)!
>> YOU ARE MINE, STEVE!
>> IT IS LIKE BEN WAS --
>> ASK YOUR PARENTS ABOUT BEN.
>> ALL MY JOKES YOU NEED TO TAKE
A DELOREAN TO GET TO.
BY THE WAY, EVEN THAT DELOREAN
JOKE YOU WILL NEED ONE.
>> EVEN YOUR TIME MACHINE RE
FERENCE REQUIRES A MORE
MODERN TIME MACHINE.
>> THIS AUDIENCE WASN'T EVEN
BORN WHEN I WAS RELEVANT.
>> WE COVER THE WHOLE SPECTRUM
HERE, MAN.
>> THE OTHER THING ABOUT HUNTING
IT IS A ONE-SIDED SPORT MOST OF
THE TIME AND  THAT'S
NOT A REAL SPORT MOST OF THE
TIME.
IF THE LION GOT BODY ARMOR OR IF
THE HUNTER HAD TO GO IN NAKED
WITH JUST LIKE A SHARP BONE THAT
WOULD BE MORE INTERESTING,
HAND-TO-HAND COMBAT.
>> YES. EXACTLY.
>> Larry: THAT'S NOT A BAD
IDEA.
>> THAT IS ALSO JUST LIKE
TALKING ABOUT SPORTS, I WOULD
WATCH THAT EVERY SUNDAY.
LIKE IF IT WAS A DENTIST VERSUS
A LION WITH A BONE.
>> YES.
THAT IS GOOD TV.
>> NO OFFENSE TO THE NFL BUT I
WOULD WATCH THAT EVERY SUNDAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> AND ALSO, AND THERE IS A LOT
OF OTHER (BLEEP) YOU CAN KILL IN
AFRICA ONCE YOU ARE THERE.
>> AND IT IS LIKE THERE IS AN
ENTITLEMENT TOO BECAUSE HE PAID
FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF DOING IT,
NOT JUST THE FLIGHT BUT ALSO A
LICENSE, IT IS JUST -- YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER.
I WOULD PAY A LICENSE TO KILL A
RICH DENTIST.
>> I WOULD TOO.
>> I WOULD DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?  I DON'T THINK WE
FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT ALL
ANIMALS.
I REALLY DON'T.
IF SOMEBODY KILLED A SHARK, IT
IS LIKE, OH, OKAY BUT PEOPLE GO,
OH, A DOLPHIN.
>> YES.
>> BUT I HEARD DOLPHINS ARE SOME
NASTY MOTHERS.
FROM WHAT I HAVE SEEN, THEY
RESCUE PEOPLE AND LIKE THEY SAVE
KIDS AND STUFF.
HAVE YOU EVER WATCHED FLIPPER?
>> BY THE WAY, I AM GOING TO
CHALLENGE ONE OF YOUR
REFERENCES.
>> NO.
A GOOD CALL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO A GENTLE
BEN RIFF IN A MINUTE.
BUT --
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
>> YOU HAVE TO GET IN THE BOB
DENVER VEHICLE.
EVERY TIME BOBCAT'S ON, THE
RASCAL SALES ARE GOING TO
SPIKE.
>> YES.
EXACTLY.
>> IT DEPENDS.
BUT I KNOW.
NO.
DOLPHINS AREN'T COOL.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY -- I MEAN --
>> HOLD ON.
>> IF YOU ARE SAYING THEY AREN'T
COOL --
>> LIKE IF WE ARE EATING IT OR
--
>> LIKE THAT IS ABOUT A COOL --
LIKE I AM NOT SUGGESTING WE KILL
DOLPHINS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GET INTO A
WHOLE THING ABOUT WHAT IS A COOL
ANIMAL.
WE WILL, WELL, TOUCANS ARE
PRETTY COOL.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY,
RACCOON YOU GO IN MY TRASH CAN
ONE MORE TIME --
>> BUT KOALAS IN AUSTRALIA,
KOALAS, THEY DON'T KILL THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE ADORABLE, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> ADORABLE SHOULDN'T BE KILLED.
>> THAT'S THE WHOLE THING.
THE AMOUNT OF OUTRAGE, AND BY
THE WAY, I AM A VEGETARIAN AND I
LOVE ANIMALS AND I -- YOU KNOW,
I SUPPORT ADOPTING THEM AND I
REALLY DO LOVE ANIMALS BUT WHAT
IS GOING ON IN OUR SOCIETY AND
THE AMOUNT OF OUTRAGE, IT IS
TERRIBLE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT WHEN AN ANIMAL IS CUTE AND
ADORABLE WE SUDDENLY CARE, YOU
KNOW?  AND I THINK AMERICA WOULD
IMPROVE IF WE ACTUALLY HAD
VIDEOTAPE OF A POLICE OFFICER,
YOU KNOW, BEATING A PANDA
>> Larry: WAIT.
AMERICA WOULD IMPROVE.
>> BECAUSE WE WOULD CARE MORE.
>> YEAH.
I FOLLOW YOU.
>> GET IN THE TIME MACHINE.
>> YEAH.
WE'D SUDDENLY GIVE A [BLEEP]
ABOUT COPS BEATING PEOPLE.
>> ALL LIONS MATTER WOULD BREAK
OUT ON TWITTER.
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HAVE TO TAKE
THIS THEME?
EVEN THE LIONS HAVE TO
TAKE THE
BROTHERS BACK TO WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> THE LIONS ARE NOT TWEETING
THAT.
>> AND ALSO BY THE WAY JUST FOR
THE RECORD IF A PANDA WAS
DRIVING I WOULD FEEL LIKE
THE COP DOES HAVE A RIGHT TO GET
AGGRESSIVE WITH IT, THAT IS
WEIRD, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THEY COULD PULL THEM OVER
BECAUSE THEYRE BLACK AND WHITE.
>> THEY ARE DRIVING WHILE
PANDAS.
>> DRIVING WHILE PANDAS.
>> I WENT WITH PANDAS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO BE RACIST.
>> IT IS BOTH.
>> RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
>> YOU HAVE THE BLACK AND WHITE.
HOW ABOUT THE BROWN
ANIMALS?  YOU LEFT THEM OUT.
AND PANDAS ARE ASIAN SO --
>> ANY OTHER INFO?
>>
>> AND THERE IS THE KUNG FU
PANDA WHO WOULD KICK YOUR ASS
>> RIGHT,
>> WHERE IS THIS CONVERSATION
GOING?  BUT I DO WANT TO ASK
THIS.
OKAY LET'S PLAY A REAL QUICK
GAME OF HUNT, EAT OR PET.
OKAY?  EITHER HUNT THIS OR YOU
HAVE TO EAT IT OR IT BECOMES A
PET AND LET'S USE THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
ALL
GOING TO HUNT?
>> WOW.
>> Larry: WHO ARE YOU GOING TO
HUNT?
>> IT IS PRETTY EASY.
I MEAN --
>> Larry: TRUMP YOU ARE GOING
TO HUNT?
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: YOU WANT TO TAKE HIM
DOWN?
>> YEAH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: WHO ARE YOU GOING TO
EAT?  WHO ARE YOU GOING TO EAT?
>> AGAIN I AM GOING TO GO WITH
TRUMP AFTER I HUNTED
I JUST WANT HIM TO GO AWAY.
>> Larry: YOU WANT HIM TO DIE
AND THEN EAT HIM.
OKAY.
AND WHO IS GOING TO BE YOUR PET?
>> HMM.
IT HAS TO BE TED CRUZ, COME ON.
>> I GUESS.
I AM TRYING TO THINK OF LIKE --
>> Larry: OKAY.
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, DO YOU HUNT TRUMP IN IS
IT LIKE WHEN YOU HUNT A DEER YOU
PUT OUT A SALT LICK?  DO YOU PUT
OUT GOLD AND HE COMES OVER AND
SMELLS IT?
>> I THINK I WOULD HUNT RICK
PERRY, BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THAT
IS A CHALLENGE.
>> HE HAS SOME ANTI-HUNTING
SKILLS.
>> YES, LIKE RICK SANTORUM.
THERE IS A SORRY.
>> RICK PERRY WENT JOGGING AND
SAW A COYOTE AND
PULLED OUT A GUN AND SHOT A
COYOTE WHICH MEANS BEFORE HE
GOES JOGGING HE IS LIKE, WHICH
GUN DO I TAKE?
>> HE MIGHT KILL YOU.
>> NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE PUT A GUN
IN THEIR SWEAT PANTS WAISTBAND.
>> YOU WANT TO GO MANO A MANO.
>> TO EAT, I WOULD GO WITH CHRIS
CHRISTIE.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
YEAH.
>> THAT WOULD LAST ME THROUGH
CHRISTMAS.
>> AND THEN I WOULD SAY I WOULD
KEEP TRUMP AS A PET BECAUSE HE
SAYS CRAZY THINGS.
>> YOU GET BORED, AND TRUMP WILL
--
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY ANSWERS?
>> YEAH I WOULD HUNT JEB BUSH
JUST TO KILL THE DYNASTY
SITUATION.
I WOULD EAT HUCKABEE.
>> Larry: EAT HUCKABEE?
>> YES, SOUTHERN BUTTER BALL.
>> YES.
THAT IS REAL GOOD, REAL GOOD.
>> I THINK I LIKE THE HUCKABEE
THING.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
HUCKABEE IS PREMARINATED.
>> A LOT OF SOUTHERN JUICES.
>> MY PET WOULD BE GEORGE PATAKI
BECAUSE NOBODY EVEN KNOWS HE IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HE IS LIKE EXOTIC.
>> WHEN YOU SAID THAT, I WAS
LIKE, HE'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> I DID MORE FOR GEORGE
PATAKI'S CAMPAIGN THAN GEORGE
PATAKI.
>> Larry: WE WILL BE RIGHT
BACK RIGHT AFTER THIS!.
IF YOU LIVE IN THE NEW YORK CITY
AREA OR ARE PLANNING TO VISIT,
GRAB SOME FREE TICKETS TO
UPCOMING TAPING OF THE NIGHTLY
SHOW.
THE SHOW TAPES MONDAY
THROUGH THURSDAY.
FOR COMPLETE SHOW GO TO
NIGHTLYSHOW.COM/TICKETS.
>> FOR COMPLETE DETAILS GO